hello everyone it is Christmas time it
is Christmas here in the United States
December 25th one of the greatest times
of the year and this is in fact the very
first Christmas that we've ever
celebrated here on my YouTube channel
and so to kick our very first Christmas
off in spectacular fashion I'm going to
be bringing you guys a very short story
from marvel spectacular 2009 about what
happens when Thanos so I'm sorry with
Santa Claus it gets his hands on the
Infinity Gauntlet and so what we do is
we start this story is that we
immediately pick up with Santa Claus as
he has the Infinity Gauntlet in his
possession and Santa Claus has clearly
become drunk with power of course he
tells the Illuminati but if they want
the nfinity gauntlet back that they're
going to have to take it back from him
themselves and we see dr. strange saying
that giving Santa Claus the Infinity
Gauntlet was a terrible idea
and of course Reed Richards says that in
order for them to really figure out how
to do this they need to take some time
and they need to reflect and they need
to figure out or understand what it was
that had led to this place and so what
we do is we jump back to 20 minutes
before this and we see that Iron Man is
called a meeting of the Illuminati
together and what a what the Illuminati
say here or what Santa Clause tells the
Illuminati is that apparently all of his
reindeer were scrolls and so when the
Secret Invasion had come to an end that
Santa Claus didn't have his reindeer
anymore and so from here we jumped to
the current time where we see that all
the Illuminati have come together and
they've brought their infinity gems and
reassembled the Infinity Gauntlet and of
course Santa Claus is continuing to be
drunk with power he's continuing to to
basically wreak havoc against the
against the Illuminati and so what we
see is that name of the Submariner is
able to create a snowball and he throws
a snowball at Santa Claus and hits him
in the face hits him in the eyes and
when Santa Claus falls down the Infinity
Gauntlet falls off his hands thereby
stripping Santa Claus of all of his
power and so Santa Claus once he begins
to come to once he regains his senses is
really apologetic about this he actually
says that he's embarrassed about what
about what's happened and of course
Charles Xavier says that that Santa
Claus just like everybody else
it basically succumbed to the negative
effects of the Infinity Gauntlet he had
become drunk with power and then it
happens to everybody and so Santa Claus
asked the question of what now the
entire basis for the Infinity Gauntlet
being assembled well so the Santa Claus
could I used the Infinity Gauntlet to
complete his deliveries but with the
Infinity Gauntlet being gone with Thanos
succumbing to its effect and no longer
being able to wield it the question is
what are they going to do and so what we
see is that Tony Stark decides to allow
Santa Claus to use the used reindeer
that he's created constructed out of a
machinery which will allow Santa Claus
to continue his to actually go about his
deliveries and to ensure everybody gets
their toys with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end merry Christmas to everybody and
I hope you guys have a blessed holiday I
will catch you guys later